alright I'm business okay thanks for
sticking around guys I know it's the end
of the day and I have a train to catch
anyway so I can take this real quick but
I'm here today to talk about GPUs my
name is Kelly Bryant I'm a developer
advocate for map D very recently but
before that I spent some time calling
myself a data science product engineer
and like Jared said I also do a lot of
things for our ladies specifically our
ladies TC and some cloud stuff for our
ladies Global which is pretty cool I
publish about play series called our
profile on the open side blog which I
like a lot so check that out if you
haven't seen it and I just want to hop
right into it so I'm here today to
convince you to be interested in GPUs if
you aren't already or you've heard about
GPUs and GPU computing and you don't
know what it is yet so let's start I
wanna talk to you about what GPUs are
and wouldn't we introduce GPUs to people
oftentimes you'll do it or you'll see it
done in conjunction with talking about
what CPUs are so GPU is as you may have
guessed an acronym and it stands for
graphics processing unit GPU processors
were designed for the purpose of
rendering images animations videos to
your computer screen but in the last
decade we've been seeing them applied to
a lot more applications it's common to
see them alongside CPUs as I said and so
I've drawn up the classic like CPU GPU
core comparison so a core is just a unit
office unit that receives instructions
and and does the processing of
calculations and performance things
based on those obstructions so CPUs are
often called the the brain of the
computer they have multiple cores maybe
like a couple but those cores are really
fancy and they're awesome and they do
awesome stuff and they're optimized for
doing serial tasks
gpus on the other hand may have hundreds
or thousands of these cores and but
don't get too excited because they don't
do all the awesome stuff that cpu cores
do they do very basic tasks but there's
a lot of them and they're optimized for
doing parallel tasks here to explain the
difference between serial and parallel
parallel task execution are the
Mythbusters
if you haven't seen this video it's
really great I just created two gifts of
it on the one side you see CPUs where
they have this robot that aims and fires
paintballs aims and fires to create
eventually this rendering of a smiley
face on a big canvas and on the other
side they've created this monstrosity of
a machine that has thousands of pipes
with a single paint ball in each pipe
and they hit a button and all at once
all those people shoot at the canvas and
create a rendering of the Mona Lisa so I
don't know if that's a perfect
explanation of the difference between
GPU and CPU but it is very fun and if
you watch the video online you can hear
Adam Savage just maniacally laughing
after he hits the button which is really
great but was talking about why people
are so excited about GPUs you know like
when I first heard about GPUs it was
from my dad actually and I think I was
in college he's an aerospace engineer
and he does start camera stuff and some
of this stuff's I don't understand and
he asked me hey do you know CUDA and I
was like dad why would I nuku do it what
is that
but hearing about it again in graduate
school and then again over and over now
recently JJ gave a really awesome
keynote at this past our studio conf
and in it he talked about how GPU
computing just revolutionized the field
of computer vision through deep learning
if you haven't seen that that's also
available online I highly recommend it
it's long but it's worth it
so people are doing really cool stuff
with GPUs and here are some other things
that they've done so
I want to talk about what problems GPUs
are good for it outlet what applications
have people found for that but first off
they started being a graphics card then
people discovered you could do high
performance computing with them from
there we discovered application in the
same machine learning revolutionize deep
learning from there even further
general-purpose computing for big data
analytics and finally database
operations so today I want to talk about
this last two kind of pieces further on
but first just kind of to sell you on
this like I know that a lot of people
get up here people from the day of
science industry and they say you know
we're all dealing with big data and like
I want to be real I know a lot of people
a lot of people in this room probably
aren't day-to-day dealing with big data
but this was one of the quotes that came
out of my are profile project by
interview project with our open sigh the
interview was actually conducted by Sean
cross but it was with dr. Julia Stewart
Landis and I love this quote from
Parrish says I learned a code and a
total panic because my data was too big
to be opened in Excel so because I was
trying to figure out science and coding
at the same time I conflated research
with data science I was confusing my
thesis questions that no one had ever
asked before with data questions that
many people had asked before and salt so
if anything comes from you attending my
talk today I hope that like even if you
aren't ready for Big Data data analytics
like maybe someday you will be and
you'll remember the stuff that I've
talked about today and and you won't be
lost in this total panic where you don't
know what to do and you think these
problems have never been solved before
so with that how much does it cost
I love Wired magazine I read it all the
time this title in it from an article in
2013 really got me though
now you can build Google's $1,000,000
artificial brain on the cheap how cheap
you say only $20,000 and by you I mean
and shooting yeah so so when I was
reading this in grad school it kind of
pre biased me to think like oh gee peace
really cool there's a lot of computer
vision applications but it's probably
not for me yet I'm a student I don't
have this kind of cash and so I I kind
of went along with with that assumption
for a good number of years but it's 2018
now so so what has happened since then
there are ways to get access to GPS now
and I sort of listed these in order of
harder to figure out down to easier to
figure out and you can argue with me
afterward whether I've got these in the
right order but these are kind of my
personal experience GPUs are computed on
your computer perhaps there's one in
your computer that you can use now I've
read that these things are more
difficult to figure out than just that
and some of the graphics cards on your
computer might not be optimized to work
in that way and so you have to do a lot
of googling I haven't bothered to do
this second you can go out and buy these
things nvidia sells them and you can buy
one and own it and keep it in your
domicile and take care of it like a pet
I I don't know I don't touch hardware
you good now here we get into the space
that I am comfortable with so you can go
and rent this hardware from a cloud
service provider and you can do it
pretty cheaply
here's Amazon Web Services you can get
one for 96 hour they go up more
expensive than that obviously pretty
quickly but ninety cents an hour
very reasonable here's some from Google
cloud all the major cloud providers have
them as ur has them I don't have a
cypher Azure
but they're all out there and they're
ready to be rented and you can go and
learn the skills to rent them very
easily but I do want to caveat this with
a couple of other thoughts like when you
or I'm assuming most our users are going
to be doing GPU compute in kind of a
hybrid way where most of your our code
is or a bunch of it will happen on CPUs
so I think CPU are and then maybe you
have a set of functions or processes
that a GPU compute might be useful for
so the hybrid approach would be lots of
Hvar on CPU and then you flip over do
some GPU stuff but you're not using it
all the time for everything so you have
to sort of think about like what is your
use it's gonna be what are your needs
whatever your team's needs and sometimes
those can be very hard to predict so are
you leaving it on all the time are you
are you trying them on turning them off
you have to learn these cloud computing
skills which I'm a big proponent of I
wouldn't be and white are our talk for
me with if I didn't get up here and like
evangelize about cloud computing so you
have to get over your fear of giving
them your credit card it's okay and then
you're probably going to waste a lot of
time learning about this stuff and
you're probably gonna make mistakes and
that's okay too but learning about the
the cloud and and how to use are in the
cloud just really change my perspective
on data science and opened up a lot of
avenues for me personally so I have a
big proponent of it the last one is kind
of an interesting thing and it's fairly
new but there are now services that you
can subscribe to where you get Hardware
GPU and software as a subscription
service so here's the service offered by
map D my employer where you can
subscribe to a a monthly tier system
where you are choose how much data you
want to ingest and then they
give you a rate based on that so I do
want to talk now about GPU powered
sequel engines and this is kind of the
core of what I do as a developer
advocate for map D I work with their map
decore open source database and I try to
get people excited about using it and
trying it out so map D has has created
this sequel database that is GPU powered
and the cool thing about that is that
not only can they do things with big
data process sequel queries very fast
but you also have access to not only the
compute pipeline inside the GPU but also
the visual pipeline so you can do a
query and sequel and then very quickly
not even having to copy transition to
the graphics pipeline and create a
visual rendering which is really awesome
because the application for that is then
doing exploratory analysis on big data
so I want to do a demonstration of our
open source database and a visualization
platform that is not open source but is
a great addition to sit on top of our
open source database and provide you
with some of the kind of the visual
power so showcasing the visual power of
the map D open source database so this
is 11 billion rows of data then I'm
visually like visualizing and the reason
we could do this is the the math T
database is doing the rendering on
server-side and it's kind of a hybrid
visualization approach where all of the
fancy visualization rendering gets taken
care of compressed down on server side
to about a hundred kilobyte static PNG
and then it gets sent client-side so
that we can interact with it very
quickly and it feels like real time
human interaction with data so we could
do things like filter very fast
take off filters zoom to new york city
and obviously you're probably thinking
like Kelly you can't show eleven billion
points on a screen like that doesn't
work so yes these are layered but but
you can zoom around and it will show you
things there's even some really fancy
stuff they do where you can show some
metadata about different points and
brush over certain periods of time
so yeah I think this is a really
powerful platform you know what what
it's lacking is kind of community
support from from data scientists from
people like the art community to come in
and try things out and and to give
feedback on what these platforms are
missing like there are a lot it is in
very early stages so so that kind of
feedback would be really useful and I
think it is really important for the art
community to become involved in projects
like GPU computing especially
open-source projects so that we can have
a say and like what happens and how data
science is affected by GPU computing and
how we can get it very quickly into our
own analyses and use it so with that I
want to say please reach out if you have
any use cases that you think would be
cool fits for this kind of solution we
have our open source projects which are
available on github and we have a
vibrant community over our at our forum
so we need our folks that would be great
to hear some of your voices in our
community and with that thank you very
much
[Applause]
you